[Music]
from the studio hanging on by a spider
thread and the guy who made the 1984
classic skid comes a film that invites
you to remember how great the original
was
and that's it that's the whole movie
ghostbusters afterlife
you'd love the ghostbusters when they
look like chainsmoking janitors thrilled
when they became saturday morning
cartoons and reacted in a totally calm
proportionate matter when they were
recast as women they're making
ghostbusters with only women what's
going on now instead of making the kind
of movie where boston made you feel good
sony will give you a 2-hour long bj to
your nostalgia for the original that's
so desperate to wash up the stank of
their last attempt by the end they drop
afterlife from the title as if to say
you want ghostbusters here we make
ghostbusters again happy now
travel to somerville oklahoma a location
that honors the original's roots by
being secretly canadian it's one of
those small towns that becomes a big
town whenever there's a car chase and he
was home to the late scientist egon see
right when your favorite character
started the ghostbusters he also
abandoned his family sorry that's canon
now embark on a new journey with the
next generation of spangler when they
move into his old trap house this isn't
a farm
it's a trap like his daughter kelly who
hates her dad so much it extends to the
abstract concept of science i just have
uh an allergy to science what are you up
to experiments ugh lame trevor a dirtbag
who spends the summer trying to reverse
joe betta towny you're 15. i'll be 16 in
february and mckenna grace's star turn
as phoebe you may remember her as young
tanya harding young captain marvel young
daphne from scooby-doo young malignant
young emma from ones young hill house or
opposite young sheldon but now she's all
grown up to play well basically young
egon i'm a scientist and while her
grandpa's awkward jokes got balanced by
two comedy legends phoebe will get hung
out to dry like a first timer and an
open mic why should you never trust
atoms
because they make up everything
that's funny no it's not
what do you call a dead polar bear
anything you want
i can't hear you now
wow
that's funny i just thought you were
being obtuse
was that a geometry joke yes that's why
i winked ah
see if we keep pointing out the jokes
are bad then we're actually being clever
come on not a single bar there better be
a bar
that's funny fine forget it how about
the word podcast that's a funny word
right and podcast why do people call you
podcast
i call myself podcast because of my
why aren't you laughing
legend dan aykroyd returns because he
learned nothing from his other legacy
sequel in fact the whole classic
ghostbusters lineup has been bribed out
of retirement and just like egon they're
saddled men who stopped being friends oh
we could barely keep up our mortgage
some actor bought up most of tribeca and
we lost the firehouse fun but because
rick moranis is saving himself for one
last honey i blew up the paycheck paul
rudd is the new yutz who gets possessed
you don't want to be here i don't want
to be here either watch him test at the
heretical limits of his own charm
because now is just not the time for
flirting my dude the only thing lurking
inside here is my slowly dying soul is
that what that smell is my life is a
dumpster fire i love dumpster fires i'm
bleeding why am i bleeding um you
headbutted a park bench all right yeah
hi
and in a touching tribute to how not
even the dick can find rest a tupac
hologram of harold remus returns to lift
the proton pack one last time you know
what that was actually a really sweet
moment
oh he's uh he's still here
guys he's not going away
is he gonna say anything
no
should we uh
should we bust him or
so gather into the station wagon for a
film that treats the originals like a
holy text even though it can make up its
own mind whether anyone's heard of them
how do you of all people not know about
this i'm ashamed
you know what this means right
your grandfather was a ghostbuster but
whatever this isn't for people who want
another goofy snl movie with cool props
this is for people who want a big budget
music and call back festival where the
easter eggs are the size of denver
omelets so screw it let's just give the
loudest people on the internet what they
really want two straight hours of
references
pick up your phone
[Music]
the sun became
wow this place is great
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to baskin robbins would you like
to try our mango fruit blast
[Music]
starring
the left gozers just a teenage dirtbag
baby
gone can i get a printout of mr
gruberson smiling
hot literally save america
jk splittings
josh gaddube providing the grunts and
squeals a muncher though craft minions i
shot the sheriff roll in a day two tops
how ray you ain't gonna be answers man
two minutes of bill murray that's a tree
now to the congo legacy sequel
egon ft
casita
and a moment of silence for ivan reitman
rest in peace
ghostbusters please don't get angry this
time
maybe i could check it out sometime
a flash drive you gotta cast a podcast
little dude it's right there in your
name
you're a third-rate duelist with a
fourth raid deck
wibble wobble wibble wobble jelly on a
plate
my myspace is still active
i'm in a glass case of emotion
end of side a turn this cassette over to
side b